[Applause]
happy monday everyone the greatest show
on television
all right they say that some pictures
are worth a thousand words well this one
just won't shut the f up
remember this dress worn by a-list
socialist aoc at the ghoulish met gala
where the masters sauntered around
masculists while the servants
impersonated the [ __ ] from pulp fiction
there hasn't been a more stark contrast
of the powerful and the plebes since i
was on the daily show
each tick ticket cost 35 grand yeah a
real working class event must feel great
waiting on snobs who paid your yearly
income for a night out
but the good news is they also think
you're ripe with disease so you better
keep the masks on
tax the rich was the in-your-face
masculist face message i just screwed
that up but i don't care
it was the message to the rich white
libs who would like nothing more than
for you to think that they agree which
is why this message was about as edgy as
the world's greatest grandpa coffee mug
but worse and not that surprising the
designer of aoc's dress happily ignores
her own message
a new york post exclusive portrays
aurora james as a notorious tax deadbeat
with unpaid debts dogging her in
multiple states it's true wesley snipes
has a better reputation with the irs
than her dress as well
she has six irs tax liens totaling 103
000 bucks on her parent company and a 17
grand fine for failing to carry
workman's cop that parent company sounds
more like a deadbeat dad
she faces legal challenges for
non-payment of worker benefits the
company currently owes 62 grand says the
post 62 grand do you know what you could
buy with that type of moolah
yeah two tickets to the met gala
her company cultured broker cultural
brokerage has been hit with more
warrants than your average ms-13 gang
member 15 to be exact since 2015. that's
at least 10 more than cat
but to be fair unlike cats they don't
involve puncturing a nightclub's
bouncer's eardrum with a stiletto
one time more than once and as she
stiffed uncle sam james company received
over 41 grand in pandemic relief she
truly puts the artist and scam artist
meanwhile former staffers call her place
of work a sweatshop and not as a
compliment
either she apparently relied on unpaid
interns working full-time jobs this is
something we don't do here right joe
not all greg i'm amply rewarded for the
work i do non-stop from morning until
late at night hey do you think i'll be
able to make eye contact soon and oh by
the way thank you for the free gruel
you're welcome
one of the joes i forget which one now
one worker claims that the designer
would force her to schedule her
dressmaker's gynecological appointments
i could safely say i would never do that
greg i moved your pap smear to 10 30.
[Laughter]
well maybe once for a few months i
identified as a mermaid and let me tell
you bacteria from the ocean is no
laughing matter down there
wow
but this shouldn't surprise you in the
world of progressivism the act of caring
about the powerless is often a way to
enhance your own power it's your moat
against criticism giving you a pass for
derelict behavior you can still flaunt
your louis vuitton bag as long as your
receipts are made of recyclable material
and if you say all the right liberal
things no one dares peek behind the
curtain to call out your scams
thank god for the emmys right
they should give themselves an award for
best tone deaf clown carnival
it's where our greatest hollywood celebs
went maskless sunday to converge in an
orgy of mutual masturbation
but if anybody should be hiding their
faces behind a mask it's these
self-absorbed sanctimonious sellouts
there was more integrity in a holding
cell at rikers
to prison u.s coasters so while your
kids must wear masks in school and while
you must wear masks at the gym and while
i must wear a mask in bed
has nothing to do with covid
but everything to do with role-playing
these recognition craving lemmings pack
themselves together without a mask in
sight well except of course for the
non-celebs the assistants the servers
and the press who all embraced the role
of handmaidens to their famous superiors
they all look like extras from eyes wide
shut
speaking of handmates congrats to that
show which broke the record for most
emmy losses in history
or should i say herstory
what a shame it had such a positive
message
yeah it turns out creating a dismal
miserable mess of male loathing only
works in women's studies classes
my colonist colonoscopy won more emmys
to be fair what a surprise ending
[Laughter]
four matchbox cars
i counted three at the time but at least
at least they were jokes
i have the results of the special recall
election
for the 2018 emmy for outstanding comedy
as you remember that year the marvelous
mrs maisel was duly elected with an
overwhelming majority but california law
does allow for the recall of any emmy
award
if enough signatures are first obtained
meaning the 2018 emmy winner for best
comedy could soon be
the marvelous mrs larry elder
that was like a four-hour drive to 10
minutes at the beach
and talk about speaking truth to power
am i right i haven't heard material this
daring since pat boone's latest
commercial for relief factor
granted he looked great in that uh robe
but it's one of the greatest things that
happened in the last decade this
implosion of awards shows which happened
because we're just more aware of their
hypocrisy turns out that the more
sanctimonious judgments these bozos make
to viewers the fewer viewers they end up
having because we see who they really
are couple that with the gloom and doom
content that's always trying to brand
the consumer is evil and you're left
with an auditorium full of virtue
signaling millionaires
terrified that their personal scandals
might finally be met with accountability
it's why rose mcgowan scares them out of
them
in some award shows are like a mobster's
trunk they stink of death and maybe
that's why the help were wearing masks
after all
sadly no mask can block the stench of
hypocrisy privilege and clueless
self-absorption the only people who
don't know it are the losers who keep
showing up thinking they're winners
welcome tonight's guest
[Music]
he's won emmy's golden globes and my
annual wet t-shirt contest tv writer
producer rob love
[Applause]
her star is rising so fast it gave
astronomers whiplash
oh manson global on fox business casey
mcdonald
[Applause]
[Music]
someone's got a case of the mondays and
lice
fox news contributor cat tim
and he's legally barred from owning a
trampoline my massive sidekick and the
nwa world television
so rob welcome back it's been a while i
assume you've been working but who knows
i uh yeah i've been we'll just go with
that i've been working yes yes you've
been uh uh working of course uh you did
win an emmy correct uh i i've been
nominated many times oh but you've lost
so this this yeah this is this is a sore
spot for you it's difficult it's a
difficult moment for me yeah because on
the one hand i like the fact you're
making fun of it on the other hand i
really do plan to be back there someday
and i will be wearing a giant white robe
that says
uh
please do not audit my 2017 tax
look at that tax there there it is
that's the rich yes you know um a way to
change the subject rod but ron oh we
want to go right back to my uh my award
failures if you want to get into what
you can't do this show if you want to
win an emmy because you'll be
blacklisted my uh my secret plan is that
no one in hollywood watches this show
it's wrong
unfortunately that's the truth this is
why this will be my last appearance
probably not the only reason it'll be
when i think that's a net plus for us
to like disguise them yeah yeah you can
wear like a little
costume and then guess who it is
i do have a people's choice award right
for what
uh for my work uh on the
on a television show called cheers oh
thank you
back when everybody used to know your
name right and i have a writer's guild
award
for uh a group writing a sketch that
appeared on the uh the earth day special
of uh like 1999 or something like that
yeah so that's the way you get how you
get awards in hollywood you just you
just do something for the earth day
exactly no that is actually a tremendous
point that is how you do it you virtue
signal casey what did you make of the
virtue signaling dress
you kind of are in the same color scheme
as aoc's dress i know it's orange but it
kind of is is reminiscent of that oh
yeah it's a chick as tyrus points out it
looks like a chick-fil-a crumpled up bag
it it kind of does but if you wore one
maybe for your birthday party or
something last week what would it say
like fix the border maybe you don't fly
on private planes something like that it
would say don't publish those pictures
but it wouldn't have been sustainable it
wouldn't have been sustainable
we have to come back to this to your
point earth day sustainability do we
care about taxes come on it's piddly and
the grand scheme of things of fixing the
world right no but it's again it's what
she's what she's saying is that the rich
don't pay enough no that's correct
correct the lady who made the dress
should care about taxes more correct yes
she should worry about that maybe maybe
in some sense but she also the lady who
made the dress purchased a 1.6 million
dollar house in la in 2020 so
she's working class i i work i need to
check my bank account but i'm not sure i
can cash in on a 1.6 million she also
hasn't paid the property taxes according
to that article another place where she
is deviant cat speaking of deviant uh
thank you did you watch any of the emmys
of course not oh
why would i
why would i but i have been following
all the news related to this dress right
okay uh and when aoc love to brag i'm so
proud to have worn this dress made by
this black woman immigrant designer
she's an immigrant from toronto
she came from a suburb in toronto and
aoc is like she worked away to the top
i'm like from a suburb in toronto
so it's just it's so rare to find
something that's completely this pure
usually there's like a grain of
something nice or true can't find it
here so congrats on that at least yes
i'm also just getting tired of the idea
that you have to tax the rich more than
you already taxed rich
you know it's it's it's a complete it's
who do you think is paying all the taxes
the rich we're doing it already and i
say we because let's face it i'm filthy
rich now
don't applaud i'm joking right i'm not
filthy rich
i'm not filthy rich
but you got to put something on your
clothes yes it has to like be a little
pithy unless you're like i guess kim
kardashian in which case you could
probably put a brand new tax plan on the
ass but for her
like you have to keep it pithy like that
so i actually saw it i thought it was
it's like the npr version of a maga hat
that's true that's basically what she
was wearing yes exactly what do you
think tyrus what is your take on all of
this madness so you're rich huh no i was
joking
i'm not rich no he said it then he
realized he said yeah he realized i was
here yeah
he's like oh hey oh hey what's going on
i am rich with friends and love
thank you
well
i guess
yes we have krugerrands tyrone let me
finish rich guy
can the broke brother on medium street
get a word
sheesh
tax gut feels what she's going on my
dress
what what's sad about this is not sad
about this it's very typical for for
democrats is like the rules don't apply
to friends and them right because if
that would have been somebody else's
dressmaker i don't know like a melania
trump and we heard all that i mean
right now would be waiting for the
public execution as they walk her out
like it's just unbelievable how much
they will let go if you're on their side
because shouldn't the woman who made
that dress be exactly who she's going
after right in fact a rich person who
doesn't pay their taxes that's literally
who you but the
the enemy and my enemy is still you
notice she's not looking at it
[Laughter]
she's definitely not um she doesn't want
to think about that exactly but you know
you make a great point about i think
whenever melania was wearing a designer
the media would go after the designer
and ask are you aware that uh the first
lady's wearing one of your dresses are
you offended by that that was always the
the story that right yeah they would
always they would always attack yeah
attack and this one literally
the
criminal is right next to you
like tax the rich and he's like yeah do
that
also what what is what is the met gala
again it just suddenly became a thing
right it suddenly became a thing it's
the oscars without the movies so you
just show up in the dresses and then
everybody looks and they pay 35 grand to
walk around
and it seems like well you're missing
the point it's the it's the new flowers
where the swamp grows because those free
30 000 tickets and 200 they got to pay
that back somehow oh very good but also
seems like it's always either
met gala or fashion week or pride week
or ramadan
it's always one of those four things
all the time you know i never noticed
that before
i'm gonna have to think about that
all right
before we go a quick
announcement we're taking the show to
nashville next week and we've just
released more tickets remember it was
sold out go to foxnews.com gutfeld and
look for the link on the left side of
the page it's going to be amazing we
sold that in an hour after we did this
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else